hey guys check it out pull my finger
okay
[Laughter]
and they shall call him jake
you guys done yet yeah we're done
now we're gonna get your father back on
his feet
how
well
would you like to go see a bunch of
naked boobs sure charlie
this was a dirty trick uncle charlie
cheers oh cheers
hmm
oh that's good
i just i keep having this nagging
feeling that i've forgotten something
hey if you forgot it it probably wasn't
all that important yeah i guess
i can't believe you forgot me
i said no i'm sorry
you forgot me
i know i feel terrible
how many kids you got
there's a town on the floor buddy i'm
okay
that's nice but i want you to sit on it
so you don't leave a wet ass print on my
leather seats
you forgot me too
yeah but i'm just your uncle he's your
father
yeah my own father thanks charlie
is there any way i can make it up to you
you want to go out for a special dinner
no
how about a movie why you're going to
leave me there too
for the last time
i'm sorry
won't be the last time
i just want to go home i'm cold and i'm
wet and if you kick the back of my seat
again with those dirty cleats you're
going to be colder and wetter
he's up on him he's had a rough day yeah
my dad left me out in the rain
i'm
sorry
what did i tell you
oh right
the play
how was it
buffo
the smash
among the highlights were a 12 year old
chinese george washington with a
powdered wig and a snot bubble
and your kid in a bald cap and granny
glasses holding a tweety bird kite and
announcing he's discovered elasticity
oh i wish i'd seen it oh don't worry you
will it was videotaped from about 150
different angles
i should tell him i'm sorry i wasn't
there yeah you should is he in his room
uh-oh
[Laughter]
japanese style
good lord are you picking your nose i
had to there's stuff in it
and where were you planning to put it i
really didn't have a plan
don't you dare wipe that on my furniture
and not on your clothes either
what are you doing now putting it back
here just
wipe your hands
why
because we are going to eat dinner and
you've been rooting around in your
nostril
it's okay i don't eat with my hands i
use a fork and pants
okay
has your mother or father ever taken you
out for sushi before no i don't like raw
fish well have you ever had it
no how do you know you don't like it
then
it's an educated guess
well
why don't you just try it
let's start with the tuna shall we
you go
that's not tuna
oh yes it is no oh i've had tuna
jake
it's tuna now why don't you just take a
little bite here
you dip it in the soy sauce first there
you go now have a bite
you know there's a girl at school
elizabeth kurzner and her mom made a
whole bunch of sushi and had worms in it
and they grew in her stomach and crawled
out of her eyes
oh no they didn't how do you know
just take a little bite
okay
[Laughter]
jake stop spitting on my rug what do you
want me to spit don't spit at all i
gotta get the taste out look have some
ginger
no jake that's wasabi what oh
my god
[Laughter]
okay here
so when did you find out about your dad
find out what that he's gay my dad's not
gay you sure
my dad is
not kidding yeah
you smell like strawberries
it's my lip gloss
cool does it taste like it smells
you want to find out
sure
[Applause]
oh brave freeze brake freeze
in there little pass
going
okay okay i'm good
no brain freeze
i don't think brain freeze is an
accurate description here
oh geez
it's mom
not great
who's that she's with
i don't know but they haven't been
dating long how can you tell he's still
smiling
let's get out of here before she sees us
how they're standing in front of the
door we'll go out the back
hey look i'm a rabbit dog
you know your body's sending you a
message
yeah it's saying i should really chew my
food more
look at that shrimp you could wash it
off and serve it again
your body is also telling you that
alcohol is poison
if it's poison why do you drink it
because there are things inside of me i
need to kill
you can't kill bad feelings with alcohol
uncle charlie
right
and you can't stuff your emotions with
cupcakes believe me i've tried
i'm sure you have
if you ever need to talk about any of
this stuff i'm here for you
good to know
whoa i felt that one of my nuts
hello
anybody home
are you gonna round me out
jake buddy how could you even ask me
that
hey what's going on
jake took the 20 bucks you game and got
drunk with a friend
why not no why not i don't have to give
you a reason dad i got my learner's
permit but mom won't let me drive her
car just because they give 15 year olds
learner's premise doesn't mean they're
ready to drive please i've been driving
for years grand theft auto 1 grand theft
auto 2
and i never ran over anybody but pimps
and crack [__]
jake sorry crack prostitutes
go get started on your homework
afterward will you take me driving we'll
talk about it later when just go to your
room i'm available now go
man if i hadn't knew how to hot wire a
real car i'd so be out of here
you guys think there are mountain lions
up here
i hadn't given it much thought
well just now
relax there's no mountain lions here
you know this is where it normally goes
bad in slasher movies
one guy falls back a little bit usually
to smoke pot or have sex and he gets his
head hacked off
let that be a lesson to you about drugs
and pre-marital sex
good parenting alan thank you
oh crap hey guys
psych
so
i'm confused is edward the gay vampire
the gay werewolf
the vampire and he's not gay he's
androgynous
so he can write with both hands big deal
no i mean
never mind
i'll tell you what's a great movie
jackass two
now i know what you're thinking sequels
suck but not that one there's just one
part where this guy puts on a diver's
helmet with a hose attached and this fat
guy farts into the tube until he pukes
the guy in the diver's helmet not the
fat guy
sounds pure aisle oh yeah it's totally
pure iowa
unless purell isn't good in which case
it's totally unpure isle
anti-pure isle
maybe we shouldn't talk
hello
crap
is that your dad
no worse my drunken uncle
i just pray he remembered to pull up his
zipper
is it on
i think so
all right let's do this
hi i'm jake harper and this is the human
volcano
we begin by drinking a warm can of diet
coke
that's not coke dude yeah my dad did the
shopping
anyway a warm diet cola product
and now i will swallow a mentos
[Laughter]
now i'll lay on the floor
goggles right safety first
you feel anything yet oh yeah it's
working if it starts coming out the back
door pull your pants down and roll over
you're thinking
hey what's going on not a good time dad
what are you doing on the floor
what the hell are you doing
i'm sorry i'm sorry are you all right
yeah we were just making a video hold on
hello
dad
yay
hey courtney
jake oh it's so good to see you you too
oh you've grown no it's just my cell
phone
jake what are you doing here
i just uh
came by to
what
look could you do me a favor and give us
some privacy yeah sure can i have a
goodbye hug jake go
way to block me dad
men
[Music]
you